star wars has a very limited bag of
tricks it's like there's the good guys
the jedi knights and the bad guys
why do you like star trek better than
star wars the reason i like star trek
better than star wars there are actually
two answers to that
i was 10 years old when star trek
debuted and that was the perfect age
for me to encounter that amazing
universe
i i sometimes joke that other people
love heroin i have star trek it was like
it was the thing i've been waiting for
and i just loved it and it's been hugely
influential in my life
star wars on the other hand came out
when i was in my early 20s and so
if i'd been 13 years old when star wars
came out that would have been
my star trek you know and uh but it was
just i was just a little too old for it
to engage me in a way that would have
really been hugely meaningful i liked it
i thought it was a very very good film
but but also i like the star trek
universe better i think it has a lot
more opportunity for a wide variety of
stories i think it's
much more able to comment on
issues of the moment you know star trek
was deliberately written like twilight
zone these were gene roddenberry and rod
sterling were both men who had a lot to
say about race about social issues about
war
and uh and they said it and um
i think star wars is much more kind of a
escapist entertainment i think it comes
from a very different place
but again it's not for me to
bad mouth anything i'm glad the
mandalorian has been successful i think
the more recent star wars films were
problematical because they kind of
didn't really know where they were going
and would go two steps to the left two
steps to the right and then you know
walk into a wall you know so it was like
um i feel very sad about that because
um
it could have been better and i i think
there's a problem when people decide
that they're going to
go
deviate from what's expected and go in
the exact opposite direction because
often
it doesn't create good art it just
creates
chaos
so i think you have to be very careful
of why you're doing
making certain creative choices because
they if they don't follow the emotional
line
um then you're not going to engage in
audience
and also an audience that feels a very
huge part of ownership yeah and the
story and the characters and that's and
that but the funny thing is the
audience's ownership of something
is a fine line to walk because you don't
want to just give them what they want
because then you're just reiterating the
same old story what you want is
to give them emotionally something
that's satisfying but also opens the
universe wider does something that they
haven't seen before but in an
emotionally satisfying way so for
instance when i came up with the idea
for far beyond the stars for deep space
nine it took us into the world of 1950s
science fiction writers which was
something star trek had never done but
it showed the audience where we came
from why science fiction was important
why telling your truth is important and
it dealt with race in a very powerful
way and
i was very very glad that episode sold
and got made and people are still
complimenting me on it
20 years later
people often don't know
what they'll love until they see it you
know and so
it's
like star wars you know if if they tried
to describe star wars before people saw
it i don't think people would have
understood what it was going to be
because it sounded like crap you know
this guy travels around with this big
hairy creature and you know and then
there's this guy in a mask and he's the
villain and he's you know
it would sound like oh jesus christ and
you know i want to be a jedi knight it's
like oh god but but then you see it
and what made star wars great was that
it was a visualization of everything
we'd been reading in science fiction for
decades but had never been visualized
that well
and so that's what set it apart it
wasn't that it was enormously original
it was that it was
transferring to film what had been we've
been reading about forever but i'd never
seen on film so that was what made it so
exciting you know flying through the
asteroid belt and all those wonderful
things the laser battles and you name it
it was it was great fun it's one of the
most entertaining films ever made so
yeah
what do you think the new star wars
trilogy got wrong
that's a hard one it wasn't for lack of
trying because i know jj abrams and i
know he loves star wars and
i think he was afraid of of blowing it
but um but he certainly put everything
he had into it and he certainly did a
lot of things right i mean the you know
building a full-size millennium falcon
for instance but um
star wars has a very limited bag of
tricks it's like there's the good guys
the jedi knights and the bad guys the
the new order or or you know the the
whatever you know
it's like good guys versus bad guys and
the bad guys have a weapon and they're
gonna blow something up and you know
it's like it's so difficult and because
you and then mandalorian has expanded
that a bit they put a baby in it baby
yoda but um
uh you know it's just
there's so many ways i mean i thought i
thought jj was very clever with his
version of star trek a lot of people are
down on that version but i think he
actually did a very good job of bringing
it alive again and finding a way of
reinventing it um
but with star wars it's like who are
those people who is who is a kylo ren
who is you know i mean he kills harrison
ford we're never going to forgive him
for that i mean it's not like darth
vader comes around at last and saves his
son which is a great story arc
it's like kylo ren put the lightsaber
through harrison ford and he fell down
and he was dead you know it's like
you know
you it doesn't go somewhere that you
want it to go i don't care if rey and
kylo ren are drawn to each other i don't
know who those people are
you know and they're like they're like
less interesting versions of the
characters that we started with you know
with uh luke and leia and han it's like
you don't
i mean like poe dameron who is that guy
why do we i mean i like the actors very
much i think the actors generally are
extremely good but it's just
you know where
where are you going you know it and and
then so it basically the first move goes
like this then the second movie goes
like that and then they try and jam it
back this way
it doesn't it doesn't flow it doesn't
pay off well at all it's just
weak storytelling and uh
but but again when you view a property
as a cash cow
then you just try to get your best
people and try and hope that one out of
every three or four will click
and because that keeps the franchise
alive and uh
it's a cynical
way of looking at things and certainly
not
um
[Music]
creative
but it's a machine it's factory but um
that doesn't mean you can't get great
star wars stories or great star trek
stories or any of this stuff some you
know it's like each time out it's the
luck of the draw it's not that people
are trying to create crap they aren't
they're trying to really do a great job
and if it fails it's it's it fails
simply because
what they tried or the direction they
went didn't didn't pay off i think you
know uh kevin feige's done a great job
with the marvel universe he's made a lot
of great great films i'm not a huge fan
of marvel but i recognize the artistry
of what he's done
um you need someone at the top of the
food chain who really kind of has a
vision whether that's rod serling or
gene roddenberry whomever you need that
person who kind of keeps it on track and
it's hard to find those people they're
very rare
if you were put in charge of the star
wars trilogy
how would you have approached it
i i would have tried my best to make it
good
no i mean here's my real feeling about
star wars in terms of speaking as a
creative artist
i think the truly the structure of the
first trilogy
is very solid
and uh but the ewoks by the time he got
return of the jedi george lucas decided
he was making films for children not
broad-based family entertainment in
other words as an adult there's a
certain adult quality to the first two
films that the third film with the ewoks
and all that it's like let's make some
teddy bears let's let's make some
products and then when he went to the
prequels
he needed
you know he was writing them he needed a
writer who was solid he needed to bring
in a strong writer because
this the basics of the story
you know the fact that that the best
jedi becomes
um
evil and is and then ultimately rises to
the occasion to save his son those first
six films that structure is really
interesting but the telling of it was
very poor and so first of all it was as
i say they were films for children and
they were kind of silly but also
the writing was really poor the dialogue
was really poor the design stuff was
great my friend ian mckay designed darth
maul
but
um but they but also when you when
you're thinking of it all as something
that's going to
help sell toys
then you're not thinking oh well look
here's this great character darth maul
why don't we give him a personality and
why don't we have him continue longer in
the show in the you know in the series
of films he was great when ray park is
fighting two guys off with you know with
one lightsaber you know it's astonishing
when he i mean he's great
and they cut him in two i would have had
him you know stuck back together and
come on back you know it's but um
but i think
there's a lot of weird vibes in the in
those first three films it's like hey
look you're a 10 year old kid and i'm
going to marry you in the next movie
it's like holy cow here's a babysitter
and then you you know next thing you
know you're in bed with him it's like
what you know it just gives you a creepy
feeling you know um
and and also of course that kid couldn't
really um act much and you know so it's
just
lost opportunity
you